Why does Mark Harmon have a reduced role in
Season 19 of "NCIS"?
And what do his cast mates really think of
him?
"NCIS," the CBS police procedural drama, is
currently in the middle of airing its 19th
season.
Having first aired in 2003, the popular series
is nearing two full decades on the air, which
is an impressive feat for just about any television
show.
Created by Donald P. Bellisario and Don McGill,
"NCIS" follows the Major Case Response Team
special agents of the Naval Criminal Investigative
Service in Washington, D.C.
For much of the show's run, the fictional
team was led by Supervisory Special Agent
Leroy Jethro Gibbs, played by Mark Harmon,
who is widely considered the face of the show.
However, in October 2021, The Hollywood Reporter
wrote that Harmon would no longer be working
on the show as a series regular, with Season
19, Episode 4 acting as a conclusion to Gibbs'
story, for now.
Executive producer and showrunner Steven D.
Binder said in a statement,
"As an executive producer and dear friend,
Mark continues to be an integral part of the
fabric of the show [...] So regarding the
future of Gibbs, as long-time fans of the
show may have noticed over the years [...] never
count Leroy Jethro Gibbs out."
Still, Harmon has exited the series, at least
for the time being, leaving fans to reflect
on his legacy.
Luckily for us, TV Insider gathered up comments
made about Harmon by his "NCIS" co-stars,
in which they reveal what it was like to work
with him on the set of the show.
Naturally, they all have good things to say.
To start with, David McCallum, who plays Dr.
Donald "Ducky" Mallard, credited Harmon with
creating a productive working environment.
McCallum said in 2007:
"There was always a certain degree of chaos
[at one point during the series' production],
but it's all gone now.
Mark was instrumental in putting our house
in order — I really thank him for that."
In 2009, co-star Michael Weatherly, who played
Senior Field Agent Anthony DiNozzo through
Season 13, complimented Harmon's on-set behavior,
saying:
"[Harmon is] a very rare person in this business
because there's no assistant, no entourage.
Mark is largely just a very straightforward,
approachable, calm, assertive guy.
He's not a people pleaser."
In 2019, Cote de Pablo, who joined in Season
3 as Special Agent Ziva David, said of Harmon:
"We were always trying to infuse [scenes]
with different things, try something new.
Mark has been here for years, and he's still
bringing it."
Even those closest to Harmon recognize his
impressive professionalism.
Harmon's real-life wife Pam Dawber, who played
Marcie Warren in later seasons, raved about
Harmon in 2021, saying:
"Mark is for the best of everybody and everything.
His ego does not extend.
He just wants it all to work."
We'll definitely all miss Harmon's on-screen
presence in "NCIS," just as his co-stars will
miss him both on and off the screen.
Being that Leroy Jethro Gibbs was the head
of NCIS' Major Case Response Team, Mark Harmon
was considered the lead of the show.
As the lead actor on the series, Harmon's
role came with different responsibilities
than the other roles in the cast.
Sean Murray, who plays Tim McGee, told Country
Living that Mark Harmon was "number one,"
and explained,
"We wouldn't be here, 16 years later, if it
wasn't for Harmon [...] Harmon is a very special
individual."
During an interview with Build, Cote de Pablo
also revealed that Harmon was one of her mentors.
"He's more of a friend mentor, you know?
He was always like a father figure to me."
Referencing their characters, she explained,
"Obviously, Ziva and Gibbs have that but Cote
and Mark have that as well."
When it came to being the lead actor, Michael
Weatherly relied on Harmon's advice when he
got his own series-lead role on the CBS drama
Bull.
Weatherly told USA Today,
"It's been very illuminating and given me
a great deal of insight and regard for what
Mark Harmon was doing all those years [on
"NCIS"] [...] When I was like, 'How come he
doesn't have as much fun as the rest of us?'"
It's clear that Harmon remains beloved by
viewers and cast members alike.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.